next philosophy pop up today I thought
we would talk about tips for students
stuff that has to do with could be high
school I guess although I don't teach
high school mostly University College
level stuff and yeah I've been teaching
for about twenty years now this year and
I have probably taught thousands of
students at this point I have over a
hundred this semester alone so I thought
I would open things up once they taught
us about a few tips for students to
questions and comments about you know
philosophy in general how to study
philosophy what to do when you get
bogged down writing a paper for example
or you've got a teacher who's not
particularly helpful David writes put
that stoicism patience to practice well
I think all of you know I'm not stoic
right I'm an eclectic so yeah this is
this is stuff that we actually should
have some control over and finally did
figure out what was going on with it
turns out that they were there were some
programs running in the background that
shouldn't have been running all right so
I see a question already coming up from
Ravi trying to work on the philosophy of
time and how important is it that I
study temporal logic that's you know
you're going to to study there's there's
not a lot of material out there as far
as I know on temporal logic so I can't
say all that much about that but that
you would definitely want to study a lot
of different philosophers and their
viewpoints on time and its relation with
other things it's a major metaphysical
issue let's jump in and talk about more
general stuff so this is the time of
year here in the United States at least
I'm not sure what it's like in other
places where students are starting to
have to
work on bigger picture assignments and
you know papers are starting to pile up
you're getting hopefully some prep for
your your final examinations because
classes are actually going to end and a
lot of places in late April or in early
May so it's it's important I think as a
student to start looking at what you
actually have to do this is where for
example time management would become
quite important sketching out what sort
of steps you need to do in order to stay
on track because you know as they get to
the closer and closer to the end and the
projects get bigger and bigger you wind
up having less and less time to work out
of things especially if you haven't
stayed on top of things up until that
point so this is the time when you want
to get as much information from your
instructors as possible about you know
what what papers ought to look like or
projects want to incorporate how many
steps there are if you have a you know
an electronic course management system
which most colleges and universities do
you want to like start you know checking
all of your grades and finding out
whether there's anything that you missed
that you need to make up or you know
whether an instructor didn't grade
something that they're supposed to you
want to download all the assignment
sheets and grading rubrics start
thinking about if there's a final
examination how do you actually prepare
for the final examination those are the
things that that the students are
usually going to be concerned with and a
lot of people put that off to like the
last two weeks of class I would say like
the last six weeks of the class you want
to be asking yourself those questions
and and getting into that genre T's says
do you have any tips for writing well in
philosophy yeah I mean the first thing
to say is there is no recipe for doing
good writing it depends very much on the
kind of production or genre that you're
working in so writing a conference paper
is different than writing
an academic article is different than
writing a summary is different than
writing a dialogue so you want to be
very attentive to what is being asked
for and what sort of format you're
supposed to put things in that is
something that I would say you you want
to check in with your instructor about
because if you have somebody who is very
used to doing analytic philosophy they
want papers to look a certain way you
have somebody who is much more
interested in continental philosophy or
the history of philosophy they will want
papers to be done in different ways than
that right and so you know when you're a
student it's not really your job to try
to teach your teacher about how a paper
ought to be written or something like
that and it's not your job to try to
write some magnum opus or anything
either it's your job to complete the
assignment given the instructions that
you have so you want to see what your
what your professor actually wants out
of the paper now are there any other
things that we could say about writing
well one of the key things in philosophy
is clarity and I think a lot of people
in all across the the raine so in
analytic philosophy and continental
philosophy in history of philosophy they
often whether they realize it or not
come to rely upon forgetting for pretty
investment because you know we have
terms that that you know have a
particular meaning within this theory or
that theory and you know they sort of
cover a lot of ground with just a little
bit of verbiage but if somebody else
doesn't know precisely what you mean by
the jargon then it's easy to mislead
them it's easy to take them off track so
if you're going to use jargon it's
probably a good idea to provide some
sort of brief description of what you
mean by it you know great example would
be the term you know in journalism
versus external
that means a million different things
across the field of philosophy right so
you want to know what somebody actually
means by that when they're using it so
so jargon and how many handle it right
is one thing you probably depending on
what your writing process looks like you
probably want to outline what your paper
should be doing and if your instructors
are like me they really don't care much
about the introduction or having a you
know a hook or anything like that they
want you to get to meet it's a
philosophical you know body of the paper
what's going on what are you actually
going to talk about rather than you know
coming up with some sort of snazzy intro
thing I mean if they're into that and
you can pull it off that's good but for
the most part we're interested in seeing
content we're interested in seeing that
you understand the things that you're
writing about and you can talk about
them in a coherent way there's you know
there's various ways to display to your
instructor that you're you're really uh
not only understanding the particular
thinker but that you can see multiple
sides of an issue so you might present
say let's say we're doing something
straightforward right
what is Plato's performs as you find it
in the Republic what are Aristotle's
criticisms of the doctrine of the forms
as you find it in metaphysics book one
and then you know evaluate whether
Aristotle or Plato has it right okay so
first you got to present Plato's
position and you should present that as
objectively as possible don't worry
about giving your own views on it until
you can establish that you really
understand what Plato's point of view is
give examples you know to show the
connections between different passages
or different ideas and then you know
look at what Aristotle's criticisms are
you probably don't need to come up with
every single one he's got a number of
different criticisms of the forms pick
the top three that you think are the
most cogent right and then
after that give your own view of the
batter and and when you give your own
view make sure you explain why you take
the position that you do everything in
philosophy requires an answer to the
question why and it requires a fairly
succinct answer to it as well so that
might be some useful advice I don't know
if that helps the other the other thing
is another you know it's tempting to try
to throw everything into a paper you
don't have to boil the ocean as they say
we did writing a philosophy paper you
don't have to incorporate every single
thing into it you can write another
paper that deals with the stuff that
you're you know thinking is really
really interesting and you can submit
that somewhere else and do it as a blog
post or or something like that
we'll catch more rights I'm taking
tutorials of Hegel and Sartre at
university next term that's gonna be fun
I think I've been working through your
half-hour Hegel series where would you
recommend starting four starts okay
that's that's a good question so there's
a very basic I guess you could call it
an essay it was actually an address
that's arcade called existentialism as a
humanism that's a really good starting
point don't take it as outlining
everything about existentialism but it
is a pretty good representation of some
of the key themes that that Sartre is
working on just like for Heidegger right
what does metaphysics doesn't have
everything that Heidegger is the emmitt
izing but it's got some of the key high
notes of it and then you know I would
you're probably going to be reading
parts of being in time so I would start
digging into that it's a very thick long
book and I don't imagine if you're doing
a tutorial on on Sartre that you would
actually read the entirety of Being and
Nothingness
but it's good to read some of it and you
know start is also a novelist and
playwright so you probably want to read
some of the plays the plays are pretty
easy reading I think and then there's
you know short stories and novels that
are particularly apt for illustrating
existentialist themes the wall is often
anthologized that's a nice short one
nausea is kind of an interesting piece I
like it a lot of people find it quite
difficult to make sense of there's also
another one called the age of reason
which was probably a bit easier to read
and you can see a lot of sart's main
themes being dealt with by the
characters in there so I would check
those out
Katie Katie says have a BS got it years
ago
I will have the financial wherewithal
the new grad school but I know nothing
about the process I want to study
whiteheads process and reality also
McMurray of Delft well there's not a lot
of people doing work on Whitehead so I
think what you want to do in that case
is if you really want to study Whitehead
you're going to need to any wonder so
through academic classes you're going to
need to find a place where he gets
taught and that means that you need to
find somebody who specializes in
Whitehead so I don't know too many
people out there who actually do work
out him anymore but I'm sure that you
could easily you know google that and
and find some places at least that's
gonna really narrow the scope of where
you would look at going you're you know
the alternative would be you know do a
degree in philosophy don't expect to
actually get a class specifically on
Whitehead that maybe do like an
independent study with somebody in the
faculty and do a lot of that research on
your own I don't know about too many
other resources available online about
like that but he's not somebody I've
been reading for a long time I was
we fascinated by process of reality when
I was an undergraduate and process
philosophy you know it was part of the
American tradition with like Hartshorn
and people like that when I was at
Southern Illinois University but I never
really pursued that much so I don't know
too much about who's doing you know
contemporary work on that mirror I guess
when you suggest a source to explain or
helped us understand Aristotle's prior
analytics I don't work on the prior
analytics so I don't really have any
sources that I think would help I do
have a colleague at Marquette Owen
golden who works on the prior and
posterior your analytics and he's very
interested in you know logic philosophy
of science stuff he might be somebody
good to ask about that
Owen golden you could look him up on the
Marquette faculty page and not too
difficult to find but I I don't know
because you know the work that I do on
Aristotle's primarily on the ethical
political works so the two ethics
politics rhetoric poetics parts of the
topics on the soul few other works as
well but I don't do too much with the
the logic stuff oh here's a good one
from good boy how to pick a topic for
PhD research should be something
practical for something that I'm going
to stipend or what I really care about
for example it's epistemology for me so
epistemology is not a topic epistemology
is a whole field how do we you know how
do we understand you know what what the
Stoics mean by prolapses that's that's a
topic in epistemology and how do you
compare it against epicurean views and
does it relate to innate ideas that
that's a topic right I mean when it
comes to practical all stuff if that's
your goal then you probably want to look
at fields like say applied ethics or
how you know theories about modeling
philosophy of Technology things like
that but you know when you're when
you're writing a PhD dissertation and in
philosophy you often begin with one
topic and then it winds up being
something quite different than you that
you're working on right you do have a
few stages where in the initial research
you have to write a prospectus and get
it past their committee but the whole
process of research shouldn't just be oh
I've got everything figured out now now
I just gotta fill in the blanks the
process of research should involve you
revising some of the things that you're
doing know you're not gonna get a
stipend for anything you know nobody's
going to give you a stipend just because
you're working on this topic or that
topic unless it's outside money it's not
going to happen from the University if
you you know there's ways to get money
out of say political groups like let's
say let's say you're gonna do it I'm
going to do a dissertation on mind Rand
and you managed to find some some person
you could do it under you can probably
get some Randi and to put up some money
for that but that's you know it's gonna
be because you come up with the
conclusions that they like right or
maybe you get the Cato Institute the
funded or Liberty Fund or somebody like
that but that's that's not a very good
way I think to do genuine research right
laughs that's what think tanks do
they've already got their conclusions
ahead of time and now they're just gonna
try to find some things to support it so
I you know if you do get funding it's
not gonna be because of the topic that
you're working on it'll be because
you're in a funded program or you earned
a fellowship or a scholarship or
something like that so I think those are
two separate topics how do you get
funding for the PhD and how do you
decide what you want to research the
other thing to keep in mind is generally
you're going to have to do research on
something that an advisor could actually
advise you about so if you want to do
something
c'est metaphor and its role in
determining how we think about things
you need to be going someplace where
there's somebody who specializes in that
work maybe somebody in semiotics or
philosophy of language or something
along those lines that's that's part of
the process as well all right
polar times what are some reasons for
being a virtue ethicists that you find
most compelling
I don't really choose the stances that I
have because they have you know reasons
for them that that lead me to that I
study things and I'm like well this
seems to make the most sense provides
some of the best explanations of things
virtue ethics it seems to join well with
the sort of things that I observe about
human beings and how we actually improve
and you know there's a variety of
different virtue ethics out there by the
way people who aren't virtue ethicists
talk about virtue you can't you know has
the metaphysical elements of virtue
that's the the groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals is the groundwork
for an actual work the first part of
which is the doctrine of virtue John
Stuart Mill thought you know a
utilitarian talks a lot about virtue as
well I just think that that virtue
ethics as a not not sort of as an
abstract schema the sort of thing you
find in textbooks but virtue ethics as I
find it in actual virtue ethics
ethicists like Aristotle or the Stoics
or you know contemporaries like Alistair
McIntyre it's got a more powerful
approach to things you can integrate it
better with psychotherapy you can
integrate it better with looking at
things in terms of politics and I think
we do need to cultivate the virtues so
that that's really what what it comes
down to for me Proform for us who are
studying philosophy outside school are
there any good online communities forums
or reddit pages that we can talk about a
ride
is yeah there's I mean you're in a
really unusual time period in that we do
have the internet and it opens up so
many possibilities there's a lot of
great forums out there for all sorts of
things and and sometimes they die out
they don't always remain super active
but if you just take for example
stoicism right there is a Facebook group
which is full of a lot of crap stuff but
there's also good discussions going on
there as well
that has about 45,000 members that's the
large one and then there's a smaller one
for people who in some respect don't
want to follow the moderation rules of
the bigger one that's got about 9,000
members I think at this point and then
there's you know applying stoicism which
has 3,400 members and there's others
like that on Facebook there's of course
the stoicism Redditt
I don't use Reddit much because it's
it's a I don't it's just not the great
use of my time but there's there's a lot
of people doing work on things in reddit
[Music]
LinkedIn actually is a stoicism group
Google+ did but of course Google+ is
going away what else there's a yahoo
forum for for stoicism and I think
that's got a lot of members that's been
around for quite a while and then
there's you know particular groups that
do that and so what you can say about
stoicism you can say about epicureanism
you can say about existentialism of
various sorts you can say about people
who are interested in that this person
or this person or this person there's
there's all sorts of really great forums
and groups out there that you can engage
with other people now of course you're
going to have some some jerks in there
but that's that's sort of anywhere you
go right and then there's also
face-to-face meetup groups I would
actually go on meetup.com and see you
know wherever you happen to be living if
there is any local groups that might be
interesting for you
oftentimes those people will also be
involved in online groups as well so
worth worth checking out I would say
Alex asks people have been talking about
to lose area a lot of people have been
talking about to lose these days any
thoughts on yeah yeah I talked about the
lose people ask me that's almost a
friend on here I like to lose in some of
his stuff like the logic of sin so I
like that I like his essays critical and
clinical I'm not big on the stuff you
did with Qatari I think a lot of
delusions are basically people who
learned a kind of funny jargon and are
you know trying to run with the ideas
but don't really know enough of the
history of philosophy to do much with
the the connections that Toulouse he has
with it he's worth studying but he's you
know he's uh when he does his history of
philosophy which I do like you're
getting more to lose than you're getting
live notes or Spinoza or Barracks Ellen
or whoever he's writing Nietzsche his
Nietzsche book is quite fun as well but
yeah he's worth checking out I don't
think that you need to become a de luz
en and see rhizomes or something like
that but that's alright
signor Pomodoro do you think pursuing a
career in philosophy is currently viable
I live in Arizona and I'm currently
studying math but I think I'm getting
the call so that's a great question and
that depends on what you mean by a
career in philosophy if what you mean is
getting yourself a traditional academic
position as a professor at some college
or university that's tough I mean the
job market sucks and it's really skewed
to the people who have gone to the elite
institutions they've monopolized the
good jobs and have no compunction
whatsoever about doing that
many people wind up never finding a
tenure track job I've seen a lot of
people who have gone from you know
one-year or two-year position to the
next one to the next one to the next one
moving all across the countryside until
they finally get burnt out or I can't
find another position many people never
get to do more than work as adjuncts and
working as an adjunct is okay if you
have a side gig if you have something
else that you do like I work as an
adjunct but I also you know have my own
the youth does YouTube channel which
supports reason IO which is tutorials
and consulting and philosophical
counseling and speaking and all that
sort of stuff and so I'm not totally
dependent on just adjunct work which is
unreliable and often doesn't pay very
well and doesn't provide you with any
sort of benefits the people who are
trying to make a living just as adjuncts
they have a very rough time so if that's
what you mean by a philosophy career
then you know you really have to do a
sort of a probability assessment what is
the actual probability that you're going
to get a job with that an academic post
and it you know it's kind of low and the
the new positions that are being created
often don't pay that well now that's one
way of thinking about a philosophy
career there's all sorts of other things
you can do outside of being a philosophy
professor with a philosophy degree and I
think it's actually kind of weird that
we we think that unless you you know
somehow get this und what we call the
academic lottery which is geared against
you anyway
unless you went to Harvard or have rich
parents or you know are doing some sexy
topic or something like that
you know the notion that unless you like
manage to do that you're somehow a
failure or not really doing philosophy
that's kind of a weird strange idea and
you could ask yourself why does that
keep getting replicated I actually wrote
a blog post about this not too long ago
let me see if I can hunt it up well
I'm talking about this so what might you
do with philosophy outside of you know
teaching academic philosophy even within
the Academy itself there's all sorts of
other things that you might be doing I
mean if you trends out that you're good
at doing assessment well then you do
assessment right and they'll they'll pay
you for doing that philosophy really
connects up well with a lot of other
disciplines so I think it's quite good
to think about other areas in the
Academy here we go okay it's called a
strange assumption about philosophy I'm
gonna put a link to it here in the
stream there's a lot of great positions
that you can have that are much more
enjoyable than teaching philosophy and
you can apply philosophy and a whole
bunch of other ways you know tech
companies and another place to hire
people with liberal arts degrees and
often you know specifically philosophy
degrees if they can show that they have
certain skills some of those are being
able to engage with other people and
help them problem-solve because we
philosophers are very good at making
distinctions when they need to be made
or figuring out how to explain something
in other terms you have to be able to
communicate effectively in written and
oral and sometimes even visually
PowerPoint communication if you want to
deal with say business people or in the
nonprofit sector or helping people in
the arts so there's a lot of work
available in those sorts of areas but we
steer philosophy graduates away from
that and we tell them the essentially
[ __ ] line that oh if you're doing
that sort of thing you're not really
doing philosophy we ignore the fact that
throughout philosophies history many of
the people who we read actually did that
kind of work they had day jobs you know
great example would be Machiavelli he
was a city administrator in Florence
home at night and put on his robes and
commune with Livie and write his his
stuff
you know many people were not in the
Academy and they were doing philosophy
just fine if you and we live in a
wonderful time if you want to shoot a
video about philosophy you just shoot a
video right you could do it from the
camera on your computer you could get
yourself you know very cheap like I have
you know a nice little GoPro and and go
to town
if you want to write books on philosophy
you can self publish I mean if it's not
good maybe people hope I hit but you can
you you know the we have this vast open
sphere because of having the internet
you don't have to just do philosophy by
finding yourself an academic position so
I think that that's good to think about
Lou asks what do you think about
globalism in the general direction the
world is headed well I mean the way the
way that we're headed is killing
ourselves by destroying the environment
so you know hopefully we'll change that
I don't know that that globalism is
necessarily going to lead to that change
that's in some respects more responsible
for it the globalism is one of those big
slippery terms that means all sorts of
things you know can you be for or
against globalism kind of depending on
what you mean by it you know what do you
think of it well I think that you know
it's an ongoing process that's been
intensifying in my lifetime but had been
going on for quite some time before that
and it's got a lot of good points to it
it's got a lot of awful terrible things
to it as well so that's what I would say
let's see yeah on your rod how do you
deal with or counter me ilysm slash
existentialism I think there's really an
important question to be addressed given
that religion is becoming less popular
by the day thanks to science well let's
start with by saying Niall ISM and
existentialism are not at all the same
thing so you don't want to blur them
together and existentialism it names a
whole body of approaches there's no one
single thing
that we call existentialism whatever
some websites or videos may tell you
they're usually like drawing on and say
sorry and existentialism
but Sartre was only one of many people
all of whom are equally important as he
is who used that term and who developed
our conceptions of existentialism
Kierkegaard is very different than
Sartre Nietzsche is very different than
Sartre left chest off one of the first
people start seeing the connections also
Gordon Brown days a little bit earlier
than him between the crews prior you
know Gabriel Marcel Simone de Beauvoir
Francois known all these people are
existentialist they're not all doing
exactly the same thing even Albert Camus
despite saying that he wasn't an
existentialist really is an
existentialist because he doesn't Matt
brought pattern and has a lot of the
same themes and you can see that some
existentialist philosophy is it exactly
responding to the prop look Neil is
right central problem for Nietzsche big
problem that Kierkegaard saw on the
horizon big problem for chef stuff major
issue for some of the existentialist
literary figures like Rainer Maria Rilke
or Franz Kafka right so you know you
don't have to cover existentialism as a
matter of fact existentialism may be
high you can't counter neol ism
what's the answer that will you find
meaning the existentialist that's saying
oh the world is totally deprived of
meaning so it's all crap throw up your
hands in despair they were actually
quite optimistic even the ones that seem
pessimistic saying we're the human
beings we create me let's get on with
the work you know let's not just take
the meanings that are over here that
seem to thee let's make our own no
meanings right or let's let's draw up on
the past and reinterpret it in
productive ways that get us something
and and this this whole process of
religion becoming less popular thanks to
science well that's been on for three
years that's the secularization project
but there's also lille around and going
strong in many respects don't don't
count it out quite yet and you know
science doesn't help be through lout
religion i mean science can't actually
say much about quite a few things that
are religious claims so there's there's
a lot going on there I would say
anonymous why are people trying to
control the social discussion for a
while the Democrat and Republican Party
have become more extreme why do I think
this is happening is it because people
are fracturing lives into smaller groups
well you know the I think you're right
that the the Republican Party has become
more extreme I don't think I don't see
the Democrat Party in my experience
becoming more extreme I think that the
hard left has always been out there and
as a matter of fact most of them don't
belong to the Democrat Party anyway and
the stuff that that people you know say
oh that's socialism or stuff like that
about people on the Left it's you know
if you actually look at it in a
historical perspective no it's it's it's
really pretty mainstream what we've seen
is is it's rather than on the right in
the last 20 years that the extreme has
become where things that have been
centered I mean I'd say there's some
issues like for example
abortion right where Democrats have
become more extreme they become sort of
captivated by their own constituencies
and rhetoric but I think there's more
when it comes to the the Republican
Party of gun rights for example the you
know the NRA position on the Second
Amendment position that's you know it's
a sort of commonplace today back in the
1980s when I was growing up
that would have been lack os-- who are
saying that sort of stuff and you know
that was not the mainstream for for
Republicans actually Republicans refer
gun control back then now is this
because our people our lives are
fractioning into smaller groups no I'd
say actually there these are bigger
groups
I mean Fox News viewers who you can also
sort of like you know if you do
statistical analyses you can donate all
these other things around them they're a
massive pretty cohesive audience the
Democrats have been struggling to
produce something like that on their own
part for the last several elections and
not really succeeding in doing so even
during the Obama years I would say that
that a lot of it you know there's a lot
of people on both sides who are pretty
close minded and you know their motive
they're not they don't know themselves
very well they don't spend a lot of time
you know examining human nature or you
know issues of ethics except in a very
partisan way and they don't listen to
other people very much they've already
sort of demonized that there's a lot of
this on left and right and there's also
other areas of the spectrum where people
are doing this and it's really sad
because it leads to a lack of
development on their part which is that
in like you said leads to people trying
to control social discussion now the
controlling social discussion that's not
something new that's been around for a
very long time and you're never going to
get away from that people are always
going to be trying to control social
discussion the issue isn't whether
they're trying to control social
discussion the issue is whether they're
doing so in a boneheaded stupid
uninformed way
or whether they're doing so in ways that
are actually better in for you know so
it's it's not really freedom versus
control that's one one sort of spectrum
right but it's really sort of like
poorly informed versus well-informed or
doing so in good faith versus just
striving to control everything for the
sake of one's own power right those
those are the differentiations that I
look at Pro fun does Nietzsche's thought
support fascism in practice I think he's
more like an anarchist since he thinks
anyone could be an uber manager is that
wrong well Nietzsche definitely doesn't
think anyone could be super punch you
know most people are capable of that
because they are weak and give in and
buy into you know society's nonsense
right then it could be left-wing
nonsense about you know Nietzsche hated
socialism and democracy this leveling
tendency or it could be right-wing
nonsense you know traditional ISM for
its own sake I mean traditionalism
conservatism these are like slippery
terms that means something new every
generation which means you should be a
little bit suspicious of them and
they're just a subject to conformism
which Nietzsche hated as anything else
you know Nietzsche would look at most of
the people across the spectrum today and
say you're all a bunch of losers Oh none
of you our uber mentioned even though
some of you who may imagine yourself to
be Evan does Nietzsche's thoughts
support fascism no not really I mean he
I think he would have looked at
historical fascism and said man these
people are just filled with result a
month they figured out a way to mobilize
some stuff there may be a few
interesting people among them but for
the most part they're fun to conformist
you know no nothing jerks so you know
his work was used to try to support
fascism right
especially as edited by his sister
Elissa
Nietzsche who definitely was a hardcore
anti-semite and who was a believer at
German nationalism right but Nietzsche
himself didn't buy into that sort of
stuff he says the anti-semites are a
bunch of idiots they're they're pathetic
and so you know yeah he's uh he's sort
of uh you could think it was a sort of a
catalyst like a corrosive agent right
that allows you to scour a lot of crap a
lot of things so all right Mick solace
asks I'm writing a paper in Current
Kant's architectonic of moral duties of
right of virtue of laud respect
I checked your video lectures because I
have trouble visualizing it any help
well if you're getting into stuff like
law respect virtue you got to go beyond
the groundwork for the metaphysics of
morality and get into the actual
metaphysics of morality where you'll
have the doctrine of virtue right and
you can get into the social philosophy
of the metaphysical elements of justice
so I don't have I don't have video
lectures on that stuff and you might
also check out some of his other
writings I mean you definitely want to
also check out the second critique which
is nice and short as well that's not
like the first critique which takes
forever to read a second critique is
actually decently short and that'll
that'll help you out but I don't I don't
have any any video lectures on that
material unfortunately all right mr. big
weak knee do I believe that pure
mathematics are analytic or synthetic so
we're talking about just mathematics
apart from any of its applications the
fields that we include you know things
like geometry you know once we managed
to suck it into mathematics after people
liked it card number theory
you know typography linear algebra
calculus all these sorts of things that
we fit into the the field of mathematics
are they purely analytic or synthetic
I mean I never really think in these
categories anyway myself but if I had to
I guess I would say that some of some of
the stuff that we find in mathematics is
purely analytic and then there is some
stuff where you know maybe we're we are
finding things that don't completely fit
there they're not contain the subject is
not completely contained in the
predicate or however we want to think
about it there's some sort of productive
process there you think about like
complex analysis you know or some of
these really interesting developments
that we have in extending mathematical
theory like you know Cantor's theory of
transfinite numbers but again I don't I
don't I don't usually use these these
this distinction to make sense out of
out of things let's see here John Ortiz
do I have any conceptual tools to better
understand a philosophy texts I mean
both in general philosophy of science
but also specific well I don't do
philosophy of science so I don't even
say about that yeah I mean for any
philosophy text to figure out you know
who the audience actually is there's
always rhetorical stuff going on within
within the text you know you you want to
sort of assemble for yourself a picture
of what it is that the
but I knew with don't get bogged down
and you know the sort of gotcha oh
you're wrong about this so the whole
thing falls apart kind of kind of thing
try to see where the authors actually
going with stuff
remember that understanding is much more
important than agreement or even
appreciation although you know
eventually down the line you don't want
to figure out whether you do agree with
it or not first you have to understand
it what else I mean when it comes to the
most important authors some of their
their major works can be read you know
in their own right and understood but
oftentimes it helps to read more of that
author so for example the Kurtz
meditation so I was really surprised to
find out when I posted some of the more
recent videos about that because I think
I'm teaching it in my classes that a lot
of people only read meditation 1 and 2
and they do that because they're their
professor only assigns meditation wanted
to and I was like why the hell would you
only read you know the first third of
the book I mean you can't figure out
what he is actually trying to do until
they get to around meditation for you
know it makes perfect sense why people
would might be obsessed with the evil
genius of meditation wanted to you know
because they don't realize that that's
been ruled out by the time I'm gonna get
to meditation three and four you know
and let alone five and six and and you
know reading just the meditations by
themselves well it's quite good if you
want to understand a cards larger
project you need to read the discourse
on method and it probably wouldn't hurt
to take a look at the principles of
philosophy although very few people do
but you definitely want to read his
correspondence with Princess Elizabeth
and the book that emerge from that the
on the passions of the soul to get an
idea about what he means by emotions and
how they work so that's that's part of
it you know you you read you don't just
read the philosophy text just as an
isolated thing no obviously some authors
we only have one book by them so what
are you going to do can't fight any more
stuff or we have very little of their
work
unfortunately Epicurus but that's that
that's part of it you know I would say -
you want to try to think about the world
and yourself and human relations and one
that what the author the framework that
they're giving you what the world what
yourself what what you know your
relations to others would actually look
like through the lens of that author and
trying to think of examples that you
might use as well all right Valdemar
have you've read some places common
tearing up because Epictetus is
enchiridion what do you think of that
it's okay I have read it you know I I
read it when I was doing work on
epictetus and what he means by prior
ASIS I think sometimes simply kiyose
gives you some interesting things but
you know some click case is not himself
stoic so he doesn't really have mistake
and like getting Epictetus right in in
terms of his own
you know stoicism I don't think he gets
prices right I think he revert back to
the older stoic position of Prayer ASIS
is just a high racist before I had a
racist and he ignores the absolute
centrality of it in Epictetus is work
but it's you know it's an interesting
thing it's worth worth checking out
I inspire really sad about the Google+
apocalypse yeah it's so today's the 29th
by next week Google+ will have gone away
all together it's too bad because I have
you know I've been using Twitter
Facebook Google+ and LinkedIn for years
and years and I have different
connections to people depending on what
medium that they're on and I actually
get you know some of the stuff that I
like reading or checking out through
Google+ it's gonna go away and I didn't
make the switch to me we because I don't
really feel like having another social
network I have enough you know to do as
it is just with the ones that I have
already but it'll be a loss it's too bad
that Google didn't support it
and you know we this is a broader topic
going back to the globalization thing
right we can you know we talk about
globalization as being this process of
you know like we're connected with China
you know the Chinese social what is it
called that social capital their network
might you know eventually intrude into
our way of doing things and you know
what happens with the EU affects us and
all of that no that's quite true
although we we tended more throw our
weight around than weight throwing
around on us but another aspect of
globalization we can talk about is the
massive influence that these giant tech
companies have over our ways of relating
to each other and doing work and so you
know Google decides to or doesn't decide
to support one of their products that
people get into has very massive
implications you know that's that's
something that I think we don't we don't
devote a lot of attention and thought to
until until it's too late
right alright ray Ray's are there any
Spanish philosophers besides Ortega y
Gasset that you know of or it can
recommend yeah Miguel de Unamuno
somebody who's well worth reading
somebody else here's an existentialist
by the way along with Ortega y Gasset
he's not writing in Spanish but he's he
is a Spanish American philosopher George
Santayana definitely worth reading as
well and in phenomenology maria zambrano
is is somebody quite interesting you
know do a lot of work on dreams images
and things like that
nobody else really comes to mind for me
unless you're talking like further back
about these iberian philosophers in the
after the Middle Ages like Jonathan so
you know he's an interesting person but
he's not really he's not really Spanish
right in the modern sense
I'm sure there's a lot of people doing
very interesting work in Spanish
philosophy but unfortunately I don't
read Spanish so I only read things in
translation and I don't I don't have a
lot to offer on that that point all
right
ideal what one book or series of books
would you recommend for a person that's
self studying and wants a good overview
or introduction to philosophy well you
know I don't read a lot of these these
popular introductions to philosophy I
would I would say you know it can't hurt
to read it so long as you don't believe
that he's actually got things right
Bertrand Russell is a good stylist he'll
introduce you to some people these are
often wrong as assessments of different
philosophers who don't believe the stuff
that he says but you know it's a good
starting point same thing with Will
Durant and the history of the story of
philosophy right he tells a great story
unfortunately large parts that are false
you know I guess if Kenny has a book out
recently I didn't take a look at it
because because I don't read these
things right when I have my students
engaging with philosophical texts I'm
not giving them an intro to philosophy
textbook I had them read Plato and
Aristotle and epictetus and we talked
about it in class so they don't do too
much of that there is a book by this guy
Stumpf that people like that we used
when I was an undergraduate called
Socrates to Sartre it's not bad you know
you could check that out if you want
something a bit more like grounded and
actually getting you into the text
Frieda cobblestones history of
philosophy which is like a whole set of
volumes that's that's pretty reliable
cobblestone usually won't steer you
wrong and he's pretty comprehensive and
what he covers that was something that
we used when I was in graduate school to
try to get a idea about what's going on
yeah so that I think it probably answers
that Ritz Vic where to start studying
logic
just get yourself an internal logic
textbook and start doing it they're all
the same right because because all the
stuff doing formal logic is all
basically the same stuff I particularly
like urban kopi who was a great magician
in the 20th century in part because he's
very thorough and he leads you through
all the different things other people
like Hurley you know there's more recent
approaches Kobe has some more advanced
stuff where he's looking at the
foundations of logic and he doesn't I
think a pretty good job but that would
be after you've been studying it for a
while the other one the other person
I'll mentioned who you can you can find
his book usually at used bookstores
fairly cheaply is Lewis Carroll he has
this Lewis Carroll symbolic logic and I
think if I remember right it didn't come
out in his own time people put this
together out of his notes but it's it's
a it's a different approach Carroll
actually was you know Louis Dodgson was
a Dean of logic and he taught that stuff
and it's it's it's fun stuff to work
with so I would never check that out as
well all right um
Cape juste I've started on my journey
into Heidegger and feel like I finally
found my philosophical direction I've
got poults introduction I'm also busy
with the history of the concept of time
any other essays or companions you found
helpful I don't use that Caesar can I
try to use companions right I go to the
primary text so if I want to know what
Heidegger says about something I read
Heidegger you're definitely going to
want to give his basic writings which
has you know in addition to like the
introduction of being in time it's got
some really classic essays like the
question concerning technology or what
is metaphysics or the origin of the work
of art you know those are sort of touch
stones you could say sooner or later
you're going to want to read being in
time and you know I think there's
companions out there for that but again
I don't read them so I can't can't say
much about that he also has another
work that's really quite interesting
these didn't you know hide here is a lot
of lectures and some of his lecturers
are more interesting than others the one
that's that's assembled together called
the basic problems of phenomenology
that's quite good that that's that's
pretty interesting
you got to know some con to be able to
understand what he's saying but
otherwise you know it's it's it's a
decent stuff I wouldn't make the end
goal for studying Heidegger being in
time I think you should you know then
you should make that like your middle
goal around there right all right let's
see here F G H - I think that paganism
of ancient Greece and Rome has any
metaphysic or it's a bunch of stories
for plebs it's in between I mean there's
definitely a metaphysic involved or
implicit in stories they may not be a
coherent metaphysic there were there
were philosophers who tried to make
sense out of these things so like the
stomach's for example develop an
allegorical approach to mythology which
then gets used by later Jewish and
Christian authors to make sense out of
their their texts yeah that's probably
enough to just say about that I mean
there are some some interesting
treatments like Cicero for example has
this view on religion where most of the
religion is basically for the plans to
keep them in line give them something to
do something to occupy themselves with
the philosopher who actually understands
things they don't believe in all this BS
the ordinary people do so there you know
that's that that's a common thread that
comes up I'd say Arturo do I have any
tips for students that have banned
grammar or usage issues when writing
philosophy pages well you've got grammar
check on most word processors now so
that that can be helpful have somebody
proof check your work
get the Franny and if you
like trade them something like I'll make
you a meal or give you a back rub if you
proofread my essay get them to do it
right that that's the that's one way to
do it
I mean improving your own grammar would
probably help that can can be done not
just by like studying grammar but by
reading good literature that that can
help you out yeah moon child asks have I
heard of the poem John Keats what I
think of English Romanticism yeah I've
heard of Keats and I read a long ago but
I don't remember much English
Romanticism I mean I'm not really that
into romanticism per se in part and
there's certain figures like I like Mary
Shelley right but you know they're doing
different stuff than I than I was really
into it's an important movement and
period but it's just not something that
I'm all that attracted to I have to say
you know okay Robert says insightful
stuff about academic philosophy these
days you have to be very strategic about
it go to UCLA work with their Superstars
get a PhD from Princeton sad but true
yeah I mean you know the elite
institutions they tend to Bogart most of
the available good positions and
postdocs and all that kind of stuff so
that's that's just the way it works I
mean academia is not any different than
any other field where those who belong
to the elite tend to self reproduce
through a variety of different cultural
means and there's sort of a ideology of
meritocracy that serves them but
actually it's completely false and
there's enough little openings for token
people to get in from lower classes or
if we want to think about in terms of
you know gender and race like in
philosophy which is very white and very
very real there's enough openings
actually people bend over backwards now
in jobs to hire women and minorities
you'll actually see that in job
descriptions you know you see candidates
are especially encouraged
should apply and I've seen on hiring
committees where they like gotta
interview a woman got to interview
somebody who's a person of color usually
unfortunately that's kind of window
dressing they don't actually plan to
hire them yeah the the job market really
kinda sucks
very alienating for people to go through
not great for people's mental health
all right Diogenes says felt like I
should share first person to get full
marks on a philosophy essay at my sixth
form on why men should have authority
and women in a Christian society okay
congratulations on getting full marks
hopefully it's not because you can
actually believe in happen you made a
good argument or something Pro feminine
philosophers who did another job let's
not forget the long history of artists
philosophers I myself do comics and
study hey no philosophy is flexible you
know yeah
Dostoevsky is you know a lot of his
characters are doing philosophy they're
talking philosophy right that's why we
include him in the existentialist canon
and there's all sorts of other people as
well F G H and I read Shorin or seorin
if I have what I think of his work
haven't rat him I've run a few glosses
on him that's about it so not something
I'm gonna get to anytime soon Cal Fonda
I'm thinking about attending grad school
in France my skill level in French is
good but I'm worried that the vocabulary
velocity will be very difficult for a
non-native speaker well then you better
start reading a lot of French philosophy
right so that that probably would you
know be the thing to do the only way
you're going to get get used to it is to
study it to read the people who are
doing that and if you've read these
texts too it's also gonna be good
because the professors might be
referring to them and I'm you-you-you
know you've got some sort of touch
points where as you get tired and you
can't pick quite as close attention you
can at least like know what where
they're going things
Stu and PG thoughts on the Jordan
Peterson vs. G jet debate I don't care
anything about it quite frankly I don't
I don't have you know much good to say
about Jordan Peterson G Jack is
interesting sometimes but you know I
don't pay very close attention to him in
part because I'm you know often not all
that awarded by spending the time to
make my way through his stuff you know
I've devoted time to in the past I
really couldn't care less with these two
to do with each other I don't think much
interesting or important stuff is going
to come out of it and it's pretty rare I
think that that debates I actually do do
anything important other than
consolidate their fan bases and draw
attention to things I guess it's a good
thing in that people will be like
talking about philosophy but then maybe
we can get to more and more important
and more interesting stuff you know like
for example what do I think of Andrew
Young and his idea of the universal
basic income 1,000 bucks a month for
every citizen I'm actually a fan of the
universal basic income idea and I'm a
fan of funding it by you know raising
the taxes on the super-rich I think that
they've gotten away with paying way less
than their fair share for a very long
time and quite frankly you know the
Republicans are going to be totally
against that most of the Democrats will
be as well because they're in the
pockets of the rich or they belong to
the rich I mean you know take Barack
Obama for example you know he may have
been a community organizer at one point
he quit being that a long long time ago
he's now within the super-rich right if
you think that he's somehow it has
anything in common with you or me or
ordinary people you just deluding
yourself any of these these people who
have managed to enrich themselves by
getting you know quarter of a million
dollar paid speaking engagements or
writing books that sell you know
millions of copies or any of this sort
of stuff they have no connection with
you whatsoever and don't care about you
at all other than sort of props in their
own little little world so I'm cool with
stuff like a universal basic income that
would actually improve the lives of many
people and I don't even care about the
fact that a lot of people would spend it
on [ __ ] stuff you know I think it's
a great thing to do
I don't know that yang is the best
person for proposing it I'd like to see
other people doing it as well but you
know I you know I don't know enough
about him to really have that much of an
opinion what I've seen so far I haven't
been super impressed with and some of
the issues that he seems to be
particularly fascinated by like male
circumcision I don't really care you
know I know that when when you know it
was up to me I didn't feel like I was
part of you know some oppressed you know
male class or something like that when
they are asking whether you know my son
should be circumcised or not right
there's there's some really weird weird
stuff out there and I don't think that
by the way I don't think that male
circumcision is even remotely close to
forced female circumcision because you
know you know cutting off a major part
of the you know sexual organ and people
who want to like say that those are
somehow that the same thing I call
[ __ ] on there you know that that's a
sign that I'm dealing with somebody
who's kind of nutty and which doesn't
mean they they're not you know
reasonable about other things but on
that that's that's nutty we'll see what
happens with the I you know the the the
nice thing about this process is that
he's gonna now undergo super scrutiny
just like every other Democratic
candidate and then the primaries and
we'll see if he has any legs in the
primaries usually what ends up happening
is two or three candidates become the
major frontrunner everybody else is so
trailing behind that the only thing that
they could possibly do is you know
figure out who they're going to trade
their boats to or some some party
platform plank stuff
so that could be interesting
all right Katie Katie please use
Democratic Democrat Party not to be a
grammar nazi is incorrect I don't care
let's keep saying what I say and you are
being a grammar nazi with that and
there's so many other things to be
concerned about if your urine on my
stream if you don't understand what I'm
saying then I don't know what to tell
you about that all right Cody Lee have I
read contemporary philosopher Stephen
Hicks work explaining post-modernism
socialism from Rousseau to Foucault so
what are your thoughts I've actually met
Stephen Hicks because I every once in a
while and I go down and give kid
lectures on stoicism Rockford University
hosted by his Institute of course you
know it's it's at considerable odds with
the stuff that he's into I think that
his take on post-modernism I haven't
read the book but I've read losses on it
I think he's getting he's wrong I mean
and it's unfortunate that that Peterson
is relying upon this I think most people
who use the word post-modernism don't
have a clue about what they're talking
about for me if you want a book you if
you want the best book on understanding
that post-modernism is then you want
Friedrich Jamison's post-modernism which
is a big thick book and it talks about a
number of different you know versions of
post-modernism and where it came from
but but a lot of what people call
modernism is exactly what a hundred
years ago they were calling modernism
you know this notion well there there
are no absolutes anymore
everything down that's all nonsense you
know so especially the thing with you
like associating it was pretty
particular with Marxism Samuel
Harrington is a great person he wrote
this wonderful book the politics of
God's funeral Harrington is a pokemen
actual Marxist
Terry Eagleton an actual Marxist
Alistair McIntyre actual Marxist all
three of them actually attacked
post-modernism of their own time for
like getting too far away from class and
struggle for the proletariat and all
this or something so there's an elite
phenomenon you know so you know that's
that's quite important mr. big week
neither in many Republicans were in
favor of socializing parts of healthcare
of the eighties the others lots of
Republicans who have like radically lost
touch with the tradition of their party
I mean here's another issue it quit
being the party of Lincoln when it
started becoming racist and this is long
before
you know into the Southern Strategy in
the nineteen you know the seventies
right they when they started embracing a
kind of genteel racism in the early part
of the 20th century they quit being the
party of Lincoln I actually found out
very interestingly this state Wisconsin
we were one of the most progressive
in the 1800's this is where the Radical
Republicans took off it was an
anti-slavery state the Dred Scott
decision has to do with you know Dred
Scott escaping to Racine and the
governor of this state the sixth
governor who I'm actually doing some
historical research on he actually
planned and proposed to have Wisconsin
secede from the union if Lincoln was not
elected it wasn't just the southern
states we're like this is this is BS
we're getting out of here if we don't
get our way it was the north to places
like this the Republicans of today and
zero
living off of his his image yeah
Republicans have changed radically since
you know our our time growing up
18 it's a pretty dark direction that
they've taken I don't I don't trust them
for anything I used to consider the left
much more of a problem in danger and I
was you know pretty empty now I see the
the Republicans and the American rock
might as is where the real danger lies
so yeah all right Robert Smith but our
sjw's extreme if you disagree they try
to get you fired
so evergreen state evergreen state is
such an exception to the rule man you
can walk down the halls at Marquette and
you know talk health you know whatever
conservative stuff you want and most
people are not going to bat an eye or if
they do maybe they'll like they'll
wonder what you're talking about all
right this is this notion that somehow
Evergreen State is the norm that's
extreme you know I mean well all you
need to do to figure that out is go
spend some time at a number of college
campuses and see what it would it's
actually like sjw's are powerful in some
places like you said and they have power
at least is new they're powerful
most places they're actually not you
know some sjw's are extreme some arts
some are you know I mean I think by some
people's standards I would be considered
at SJW right because I think you know
Mary Wollstonecraft was right about
feminism that men and women really ought
to be afforded exactly the same
opportunities and that's sometimes we
have that means that we have to say
women have been screwed over so we're
going to give them extra opportunities
right now you know I think for some
people that would be enough to place me
in the SJW camp but that's just a sign
of like this black and white kind of
thinking about about these matters you
know all right I inspire gun rights were
seen as extreme in the 80s for many
reasons because it being a healthy State
just contrasted with a height of
government corruption they had that and
it doesn't make sense I'm not sure what
you mean the height of government
corruption they had in the eighties I
mean we have a lot of government
corruption
I mean I just have to go south to the
city of Chicago and we have a police
force that's totally out of control and
has been out of control for decades and
routinely lies about about things the
city itself is run by a Rahm Emmanuel
you know there's a great example of the
Machine Democrats you know so he doesn't
care about anybody other than the people
who put him in power I don't know what
you mean by the 80s were somehow more
corrupt tend today yeah
all right tatianna hey Greg here's
another academic trying to use YouTube
as a teaching space anyway we could
connect to discuss YouTube in academia
yeah email me I mean it's easy enough to
find my email on reason IO or like
everywhere else that's that's usually
how people get get in touch with me some
people do it through Facebook so people
do it through YouTube but sure yeah go
ahead and send me something about what
you're interested in doing fgh have you
read any theories that go against the
theory of evolution like theories of
involution which say the exact opposite
I don't know what the exact opposite of
evolution would be what that we we it's
sort of like you know when we deal with
bizarro land you can't really have the
Czar or land where like yes means no and
up means down and all this because it
sooner or later you have to have some
baseline where then we have the
opposition you know following from that
well what would be the opposite of the
theory of evolution which you retain the
you know passing on genetic
characteristics and struggle for
survival and and adaptation and stuff
like that which things would you take
out or reverse or would you say that
like everything gets worse and worse I
don't I don't even know what that would
mean so yeah alright I near do I mean II
would thanks mister standard I've been
following your work for a while find the
very interesting please continue
appreciate it yeah I'll be continuing I
have no plans to stop this is Benny
a slow month for me in part because my
wife and I were trading illnesses the
first part and I'm still teaching a lot
of classes and know my kids have been
here for for the last almost week so I
haven't gotten that much done but I keep
on turning out videos and getting back
into and especially in the summer
general lead I know anything about Jehan
Walton on the Genesis creation and
interpretations in the ancient Near
Eastern context
the name sounds familiar but I don't
know it was he doing comparative work
and in mythology or something that could
that could possibly be what how I
encountered it let me look at the next
one so and I actually I'm gonna have to
wrap up in about five minutes or so my
kids and I are gonna take the Milwaukee
streetcar for which is free right now
being sponsored by the casino we're
gonna ride it and then go down the lake
and hang out for a bit
all right Patrick says any
recommendation on how to approach
meaning and time being in time well it's
it's a you know it's a big thick book
right and Heidegger is using a lot of
terminology some of which he's drawing
from the tradition and some of which he
is creating himself and some of which
he's like immediately employing without
telling me what it means like you know
on take versus ontological right and
you're like what the hell is this stuff
right so what I would say is you know
you try to read your way through it and
if you want to use secondary lid or you
know I've got videos on the introduction
of being in time that might be helpful
you use that sort of thing and try to
get through as much of it as you can and
then like go back and start again right
and don't expect to understand
everything along the way I mean you can
see the same thing for starts being in
nothingness or Hegel's being in time or
even shorter works like the carts
meditations or Plato's Republic
I expect to read and reread
that that's just par for the course when
it comes to the philosophy work lead
rates say that we have this great
platform yet there are just a bunch of
LARPers and political edge lords you
know I've been kind of fortunate in that
I haven't encountered all that much of
that but I also tend to when I get you
know comments on my videos that I think
are kind of jerky whether it's from the
left or the right
I often just remove them and sometimes
just ban the person because I'm like
they don't need to be here and I don't
spend too much time like going out into
other people's videos when I do and I
look at the common streams I'm like holy
crap is this stuff toxic you know even
what I like look at I like looking at
you know music videos from metal bands
that I did yeah and you know you read
down and people are like so mean to each
other right and so yeah we we don't we
don't do that much with that I actually
joke with my students sometimes too
about like what we do with the internet
in general and I said imagine that we
have like aliens come here and they've
been observing us for a long time the
like okay they doing the Industrial
Revolution
all right they've got like you know
radio oops
you know they set off atomic weapons oh
they're doing this or that I'm gonna
Majan they get to the point where like
oh look they've got this massive inter
communication network they call it the
internet or the World Wide Web
this is really great because now they're
gonna make all this scientific progress
and everybody's going to be able to know
about you know humanity and they will
use it as this great research tool it's
going to connect them together and then
they come down here they're like we're
ready to reveal ourselves to you and
then they start looking at what we
actually do with the internet they're
like we're so disappointed in you
we're like what do you just disappointed
it they're like well you've got this
great internet thing and what you use it
for we're the greatest bandwidth is is
buying and selling crap porn and gaming
that's that's what you're using your
bandwidth for primarily what the hell's
wrong with you as a species
but you know that's that that's right
Jared Jenkins writes questions about the
atheist
looks like there's gonna be quite a few
questions I'm just dying to be able to
get to is boethius essential for
medieval scholastic philosophy yeah he
actually is he's not just somebody who's
important to read for the history of
philosophy and because he's great to
read for his own sake but boethius's
commentaries on like Aristotle's
categories and his translations too were
very important for people from Anselm
and Abelard onward into scholasticism so
you'll see for example Thomas Aquinas
bringing him up I'm not you know I don't
read that much of later scholastic
philosophy so I don't know how often
they refer to be theists but I'm sure
there there's some of that so I think
that that's good to think about let me
it was right 329 so I'm going to skip
ahead Riley why isn't it the case that
most philosophy departments in the u.s.
are overwhelmingly analytic wise is the
case and is this an issue
I wouldn't say most of them are I would
say it's more like say 65% probably and
a lot of them are pluralistic which
means that they have some analytics some
people doing history of philosophy some
people doing continental some people
doing other stuff why is this well
because the analytic philosophy was a
sort of sexy research program that
caught on and also there's a back
history of them like aggressively
promoting it like I remember back and
when I was a graduate student I couldn't
go to DePaul which I was one of the
places I applied to because the
analytics and Continentals couldn't get
along fought with each other the
Continentals pushed all the analytics
out of the department they no longer had
enough faculty to offer a PhD in
philosophy Southern Illinois University
the analytics had tried to push the
American and continental philosophers
out of the philosophy department for
years and years before I got there so
there's a lot of aggressiveness a lot of
like you're not doing real philosophy
you're doing poetry instead or crap like
that it's not really like that so much
these days it's more like analytic
philosophers
for the most part just don't learn how
to do other approaches and so they have
no idea what they're encountering when
they run into somebody who's doing you
know classical American philosophy or
continental stuff or history of
philosophy or things like that let's see
what else can I take here very quickly
there we go subconscious qualms do I
think philosophy is more in common with
the sciences or literature depends on
whose philosophy there's no standard
agreed-upon
consensus definition of philosophy
there's many ways of doing it some are
more oriented towards the sciences and
you could say well what Sciences Natural
Sciences yeah some of them social
sciences yeah some of them as well of
course the Natural Sciences and Social
Sciences also came out of philosophy
historically literature yeah some are
more oriented towards that some are more
oriented towards towards other things so
there's there's no easy way to answer
that Andrey SES when I read the spheres
trilogy by Peter slaughter dick
I haven't read Peter cylinder dick yet I
hope to get to him someday
that would be nice all right let's see
here
what else can I take here to do oh
here's a good one
any tips for reading difficult texts or
books will not feeling like it when
you're quickly distracted you're being
sleepy do you need to read on these day
to train your reading muscle well you
can't do you can't do too much right and
and I've had that experience myself
where you're like you have the same page
in front of you and your eyes are going
across it and you realize you just been
like sort of like a horse going through
its plowing and you know like what the
hell did I just read I don't remember
any of this and then all right what I do
is I stop and I go back and I start
rereading it
some days you just can't make progress
right like with Hegel for example there
are some days when I pick up Hegel's
phenomenology and I'm like come to shoot
a video
start putting stuff on the board and I'm
reading it I'm like what the hell is
this crap I can't make any sense of it
well then that day I can't read Hegel I
got to do something else instead so then
I pick up some Descartes or you know do
work on the Stoics or something else and
I think with some philosophers it's
tougher to read them than others
sometimes it's because they're boring
and dry sometimes it's because there's
an intrinsic difficulty to what they're
doing so I would say you know just
you'll find that the best time of the
day for reading and set that aside and
use that as your time and space for that
and you know you don't have to try to
read everything and understand
everything it's enough to get some
progress and then make it a little bit
more progress and make a little bit more
progress so all right let's see I'm
going to scroll down and see what else
we got later here's an interesting
question should complex philosophy be
forced by law to speak and simple
declarative sentences no I mean nobody
should be forced by law for that right
and you know you certainly certainly
could could try to do something like
that and that would probably be like
news speak in 1984 and that's not gonna
convey very much right why is it that a
follow up why is it complex philosophers
write in long complex sentences because
reality is complicated I mean there's no
way around that I mean you can have a
nice simple formulation but it's going
to be false
it's if you wanted to do justice to the
complex reality that we live in and the
complex reality that we are that's just
the way it's going to be and you can
complain about it or you can you know
try to rise to it as best as you can
Vava noch asks any plans to do a video
about letting us
none in the immediate future somebody
was asking me about that last week I do
Commission video so if somebody really
really wants me to do stuff they could
they can hire me to do core concept
videos some people do that with hiding
or a while back but I mean I'm not
teaching letting us that I need my
classes and the priority for right now
is shoot video stuff on the things that
I can use in my classes for my students
let me know this is somebody quite
interesting I like him I don't like
loving nasty as much I have to admit
because they're always like oh you're
facing the other and we're all
hypocrites you know there was a stick
that they did back in the 1990s that you
got like sick of after after a while I
actually dated 11 Ossian for a while to
a man's that did boy 2 that stick it old
quick you know yeah let's see let me see
if I can take one more thing very
quickly and then I'm gonna head out and
get on the road a little bit well here's
an interesting thing from me on sphere
it may seem like we're more corrupt now
and that may be true on the grand scale
but at least yeah but at the local level
we the people of Moore say now on the
likelihood of our issues being seen and
addressed have drastically increased you
know I would say that in a lot of cases
that's quite true and part that's
because of the social media you can put
stuff on Twitter and be like this is an
outrage and people feel like really it's
an outrage let me take a look at it you
know then they'll they'll spread it as
well I don't know that it always changes
things you know you look at some of
these things that we you know for
example one of the reasons why Ferguson
was having such a bad race relations it
was because they were actually having
bad class relations because the city was
set up to be predatory in its fining and
jailing of people and it was really
falling hard
on the port was actually part of their
revenue stream for the city and that
should just be criminal the treating
people like that as just mere things to
farm it may as well be the matrix except
it's the city administrators as the
machines and all these people getting
sucked everything out of them and it
happened to coincide with race and other
things and it didn't change right away I
mean all these protests and stuff like
that they've took the DOJ like actually
coming in and looking at it having a
report and it's still not a great place
you know frankly if I lived in Ferguson
I'd get the hell out of there you know
we have a lot more opportunities I would
say for organizing and for getting
information out there and so maybe we
can attack corruption more easily that
way but man it seems like there's an
endless stream of it and when it comes
to things like the Chicago Police
there's not a lot of progress being made
there's still you know holding people
without charging them in secret
locations we're constantly finding
revelations about how they abused their
power the mayor doesn't seem to really
care much people are organizing and
protesting I follow some of them because
I care about this issue but it's very
difficult to get much done about it and
when it comes to the larger political
process it's hard to see how you would
actually manage to stay in it without
being corrupted by it you know
especially in a state like Illinois for
example but even here in Wisconsin we've
got our problems that way too
all right so I'm gonna call it a day
and and this broad cast probably trim
off the first front of it when the sound
stuff wasn't working right thanks for
everybody for your questions and
comments and we'll do two of these next
month as usual I'll figure out what the
theme will be we do one on Facebook live
one on YouTube live we'll have the AMA
as well so you can you know watch the
real
Events Calendar for that you also have
the update video talking about that as
well so all of you have a great
afternoon if you're here in this
hemisphere or evening or morning or
whatever it is whatever you happen to be
and I'll see you next month